[Music]
once the Fani kicked off her first ever
Las Vegas residency last night and Kelty
night went to holla at when today
do you strut down in your little cowgirl
outfit and said this is a fantasy
because you get to do it in front of
Blake Shelton
[Applause]
what did he think of the costume was it
his fantasy I thought you know he's like
my bestie so I don't know I was trying
to ask him we haven't got to he had like
come and then leave he's doing the
blinds today so he was like why the
Blind Auditions otherwise he is a fairly
man and he could do that Blake who had
cute four-year-old Apollo on his lap set
front and center supporting his
hollaback girl backstage this was the
scene like all so surprised when but
these the moment of the night for me and
you're just saying you were unlucky in
love and it was all falling apart
there's a lucky in love but then there's
unlucky in love what was that moment and
how did you move on from that I feel
like everyone knows what that moment was
that moment happened to me a lot through
my my my love life and everybody knows
what my love life is because there's
only couple of Kelty was part of the
sold-out crowd which got to witness win
sing live for two hours as she debuted
her just a girl show at Planet Hollywood
the 48 year old had about five costume
changes and two wardrobe malfunctions
do you have a favorite costume you like
came down those stairs stomping in those
like thigh-high glitter boots it's just
always like those budget restrictions
where you're like I want more diamonds
and you're like I don't care is like pay
to play let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]